Speaker 1: Another Keeping Them Honest moment.
People are climbing over Donald Trump's 15
billion dollar border wall with ladders made
from five dollars in raw materials.
We have a new report from the Texas Monthly
that the US Mexico border wall is being regularly
breached using homemade ladders.
Border Patrol.
I mean, it's this would almost be a comedy
if it weren't a tragedy.
Border Patrol officials are regularly finding
discarded ladders beside the wall.
The walls are the ladders are so cheap that
they just it's five bucks in materials and
then they just get left behind.
And one activist told Texas Monthly that the
latter is defeating the wall that cost 12
million dollars per mile, contained five dollars
worth of ingredients of materials.
U.S. Border Patrol officials who monitor the
wall frequently are finding the ladders made
by unauthorized immigrants who cross into
Texas along certain parts of the wall.
The Texas Monthly report cites Scott Nicol,
who's an activist and Texas resident, as Business
Insider reports, saying, quote, These ladders
are probably five dollars worth of hardware
and they're defeating a wall that cost 12
million dollars a mile in that location.
He also added.
Unlike unlike the wall, the ladders are functional.
Trump, of course, promised to build an impenetrable
wall across the entire US Mexico border by
the end of his first term, which Mexico would
pay for.
Trump did not build the wall.
Mexico didn't pay for the little bits and
pieces that Trump did build, and it is not
impenetrable.
There are videos dating all the way back to
when, you know, years ago of people scaling
the wall, using a ladder and then sliding
down the other side with about a hundred dollars
worth of stuff from a hardware store.
Now they are finding ladders often made from
just a few dollars of scrap lumber and regularly
finding them all up and down that that that
border wall.
Border Patrol now drives around, grabbing
the ladders and destroying them and then putting
them together into piles, which later are
hauled off into landfills.
So like every aspect of this is just mind
numbingly, mind numbingly stupid.
And in total, Trump, after pledging Mexico,
would fund the work.
Mexico didn't pay for it.
And the 15 billion that went into it came
from federal taxes and only something like
50 miles of new 50 or 90 new miles of actual
border wall were built.
So we are it's going to take years to learn
the full scope.
Of the scam that was the Trump presidency,
sweetheart, crony deals that never end up
happening, announcements of jobs and factories
that never end up happening, an impenetrable
wall that supposedly would be completed by
the end of the first term, paid for by Mexico,
which wasn't paid for by Mexico and wasn't
completed and was scalable or passable with
just a few dollars of discarded lumber.
It's all been a major, major scam, and it
will take some time for us to know the full
scope of it.
Sad more than anything, I take no pleasure
in it.
It's humiliating, actually, when you talk
to people from other countries, what's going
on?
We have a fantastic program for you today.
Let me know your thoughts on the wall failure
by finding me on Twitter at David Pakman.
We will take some of your calls.
I will answer some of your questions and so
much more coming up today.